I got the heated electric lunch box
from the TikTok shop,
and this is how it comes.
So it comes with a little cooler bag
so you can keep your food
cold until it's time to reheat it.
I thought it was more like a crock pot.
Like, it would keep the food.
I could warm the food and it would keep it warm,
but that's not what it is.
Your food is gonna be cold as the staple,
then you have to be able to heat it up right away.
So this isn't good for kids in school,
which I thought it would be,
but it is good for a mom who doesn't wanna have to,
you know, always buy food when you're out.
You could keep your own fucking yummy
cooked food that you made nice and ready to go,
and then just plug it in your car when it's time to eat,
or plug it in your office or wherever you're at.
So I do really like it.
Has a huge capacity.
Like, there's no way I need that much fucking.
That's a lot of fucking food.
So I do really like it.
It was just different than I thought it would be.
And here comes the little Chargers.
But he has its own little key.
I got, like it.
If you want to order one,
the link is right here.
It's definitely okay. Ish.